[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau c'est 8 etc
aujourd'hui focus sur la deuxième grande
soirée des entrepreneurs cette année
l'événement a pour thème l'innovation et
la digitalisation de l'économie
plusieurs grands acteurs du territoire
feront part de leurs expériences et des
défis liés à la révolution numérique
mais tout de suite on passe au sommaire
jean michel fourgous vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines est en charge
du développement économique
nous verrons avec lui des forces
économiques du territoire rencontre avec
xavier de roux est un des finalistes du
concours organisé dans le cadre de cet
événement le directeur de la société et
innovent développe une montre connecter
pour garantir la sécurité des personnes
atteintes d'alzheimer
et puis focus sur l'entreprise et
pommades la start up a créé une
plateforme dédiée au financement des
étudiants en difficulté
[Musique]
san quentin en yvelines ses 145 mille
emplois 16 mille entreprises 2009 100
établissements commerciaux et six grands
pôles économiques
faisons maintenant un point avec jean
michel fourgous vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement économique qui a contribué
à mettre en place la grande soit avec
des entrepreneurs
bonjour monsieur fonds bouffe jours
alors dites moi c'est important il faut
y être à cette soirée des grands des
entrepreneurs à m'écouter
c'est ce1 entrepreneur c'est quelqu'un
qui produit des solutions pas les
problèmes maison des solutions et on a
particulièrement besoin en ce moment
dans notre pays de faire monter un peu
les gens qui produisent de la solution
qui la met en place concrètement pas
uniquement in his cours et mais ils sont
là il y en a ce soir près de six ans ça
se passe n'est sûr dans un espace et un
modèle de l'excellence entrepreneuriale
française bouygues
qui est le symbole des bâtisseurs dans
le monde
et en fait on c'est l'occasion que ces
600 entrepreneurs voient un peu les gros
les moyens les petits et puis les mettre
face à la réalité avec ce concours où il
y avait des aux entreprises les groupes
ceux des tpe et puis des jeunes pousses
c'est vraiment créé cette émulation il
ya un besoin mais c'est bien sûr il y
avait bien sûr la sauce idées des jeunes
pousses ce soir les plus innovants les
start up et bien déjà de les mettre dans
le milieu en l'hébergeant qu'en plus
d'expérience pour qui les échanges
d'expérience c'est comme ça que les gens
se réalise
1 c'est pour ça que souvent on dit on
sort quelqu'un qui est dans un milieu où
il se passe rien on le met dans un
milieu où sabine van où ça bouge on est
dans une culture de solutions bas la
personne se convertit et prend cet état
d'esprit qui fait gagner qui fait réussi
à l'individu donc bien sûr c'est un
milieu qui est là pour faire réussir
pour trouver de nouvelles solutions
crédit entreprises créent des emplois
marchands faire entrer des nouvelles
recettes fiscales et sociales dans les
caisses de l'état qui sont vides
bien entendu que donc c'est un beau
symbole ce soir 7 soit entreneurs une
fois par an saisonniers un rendez vous
important absolument de considérations
d'abord pour eux parce qu'après tout
c'est eux qui payent de ça c'est faux
bien avec ces entreprises qui payent le
train de vie de l'état c'est pas le
contraire
donc voilà leur dire qu'on est là que
mon véritable proximité mais on est à
leur disposition
on est vraiment leur service souvent
l'état ya une profusion se demande si on
était seul et a oscillé taquet toujours
notre service bon donc nous ce soir on
leur montre bien qu'on est l'étape
proximité contre mais qu'on est à leur
service à leur disposition prenez là
pour leur simplifier la vie dans une
houle ont dit leur problème c'est c'est
trop de taxes et d'impôts c'est c'est
trop de complexité administrative fait
par des gens quand je vais me entourés
de leur vie dans ça c'est insupportable
et puis aussi mon le problème du droit
du travail on est ici complètement les
conditions de travail vont donc
donc voilà c'est simplifier tout ça et
ils ne sont pas ces spéciales et on est
là pour l'entendre et faire remonter au
plus haut niveau que on adapte des lois
qu'on adapte les modes de financement
qu'on adapte bien sûr tous les circuits
de dead à la recherche donc l'avc pour
réconcilier un peu d'abord l'entreprise
et l'état aussi c'est un accessoire est
symbolique là dessus et puis qu'ils
fassent du business ensemble bien
entendu il faut qu'ils améliorent leur
chiffre d'affaires leur rythme on l'a
senti ça dans votre discours pendant la
soirée cette envie de faire grimper
saint-quentin de mettre en avant les
entreprises c'est ça l'agglomération
un bon mot je rêverais effectivement
d'être le bateau amiral savez
la deûle à la flotte
française au niveau de l'économie que
cet avenir soit encore plus le symbole
de l'innovation
de produire de la richesse
de quoi des emplois marchands durable il
entendu bien sûr
m'envoyer enchanté d'être d'avoir à
piloter ce beau projet qui en plus c'est
l'intérêt général et bien je remercie
monsieur faurecia
merci
[Musique]
l'agglomération aide les entreprises à
se développer notamment grâce au stick
hulk et soutient les dirigeants faisons
un point avec et pommades une plateforme
dédiée au financement des étudiants
il fait partie des huit entrepreneurs a
participé à l' aventure du ski cube yves
perrachon y développe sa start up et
pommades celle ci doit permettre de
financer les étudiants durant leurs
études supérieures
la réalité c'est deux millions cinq cent
mille affiliés en france c'est une miss
en trente mille étudiants qu'on pourrait
qualifier pour un exemple 2016 record
d'inscriptions restos du coeur des
étudiants on est vraiment dans la
pauvreté donc ses 830 mille étudiants
aujourd'hui ne sont pas financés
on peut prendre un autre exemple la
grande bretagne 40 % des étudiants
financer la france 10%
donc on voit que 90 % sont en hausse
périmètre et pour lutter contre les
difficultés de financement des étudiants
l'ancien salarié du crédit agricole
souhaite leur octroyer la somme de 7500
euros par an une somme qui sera
contrôlée en temps réel ils ont un
bouton et pommades qui leur permettra de
rentrer et de configurer leur profil
dans leur filière et donc d'affecter un
certain nombre de budgets et de type de
budget pour leurs dépenses futures
ensuite sur le site et pommades qui
créeront leur moyenne paiements
numériques via leurs smartphones et
leurs comptes via leur smartphone en
fait après ils n'utiliseront que leur
smartphone leur pc pour exécuter toutes
leurs dépenses et et utiliser la
solution est romagne l'objectif pour
yves perrachon et de démarrer à la
rentrée étudiante en octobre 2017
il souhaite dans l'avenir étendre sa
plateforme aux start up
et le territoire ne cesse de se
développer une trentaine de projets
immobiliers sont en cours de
développement soit 250 mille mètres
carrés saint quentin en yvelines est le
premier pôle commercial des yvelines le
premier acteur majeur du cluster
paris-saclay la première agglomération
en pib par habitant avec six filières
d'excellence l'automobile l'aéronautique
le btp l'énergie l'environnement la
santé la banque et le numérique
et parlons-en du numérique avec
l'entreprise et innovent basée à trappes
elle développe une montre connecter pour
garantir la sécurité des personnes
atteintes de maladies cognitives dont
alzheimer elle participe d'ailleurs au
concours des entreprises organisé à
l'occasion de la grande soirée des
entrepreneurs reportages et 46,1
millions de personnes atteintes de
démons
tu seras 1 million 250 mille cas en
france en 2020 et cela doublera tous les
20 ans et pour répondre à cette
problématique
xavier drouet a créé et innove en mars
cette société basée dans la pépinière et
villages d'entreprises de trappes a mis
en place une montre connecter les teams
watch le projet des teens aux c'est une
montre connectés qui est spécialisée
dans les maladies cognitives dont
alzheimer et qui va permettre de
sécuriser les patients dans les familles
et dans les ehpad la montre est composé
de capteurs
l analyse en temps réel les commissions
du patient aucun produit aujourd'hui
type gps géo localisation utilise
personnes utilisent ce type de produits
le produit intègre beaucoup de capteurs
liés au médical pour impédance
température des capteurs qu'on appelle
accéléromètre pour détecter les chutes
d'un patient à distance et en fait la
technologie c'est le la montre va
envoyer des sms à la famille ou centres
médicaux pour envoyer des alertes en
fait des premiers tests seront effectués
sur 20 patients atteints d'alzheimer à
l'ehpad de plaisir grignon le lancement
de l'été watch est prévue pour 2018
eh bien nous sommes avec monsieur drouet
qui vient de gagner le concours
il avait une minute pour de deux minutes
c'est vrai pour montrer son projet les
teams watch alors ça s'est passé comment
il a coûté très bien puisqu'on a gagné
le concours le leti watch est un projet
très intéressant actuelle notamment pour
sécuriser les malades d'alzheimer
donc c'est un projet innovant avec ce
qu'on appelle de l'internet par l'objet
d'objets connectés et c'est un plus
comme ça d'être devant un public c'est
public à voter pour vous faire gagner
c'était déjà un test pour voir si les
tiguan ça fonctionne oui parce que c'est
la première fois qu'on communique au
niveau du projet il y aura des
prochaines fois certainement des deux
victoires espère on espère donc oui
c'est un projet qui est intéressant et
qui touche tout le monde
et bien je vous remercie puis je vous
laisse repartir avec vos prix
et je suis avec madame corbin directrice
de l'entreprise corbin une tpe
saint-quentinoise qui est spécialisée
dans la réparation de moteurs
électriques
bonjour monsieur vous étiez jury ce soir
lors de ce concours
alors j'ai participé au vote sur les
différents projets qui étaient présentés
tous très intéressants
qui les notes du caractère innovant de
la territoire alors pourquoi vous avez
décidé de participer à cette grande
soirée des entrepreneurs en plus je
crois que c'est la deuxième fois
voilà j'avais été invité l'année
dernière et c'était une soirée qui était
ma foi très sympathique et qui permet
aux entreprises aussi de se rencontrer
moi étant une petite entreprise sur
elancourt c'est aussi l'occasion de
rencontrer d'autres d'autres personnes
et puis ce soir il y avait en plus des
remises de prix de sociétés innovantes
avec des projets qui peuvent être
intéressants et qui peuvent déboucher
sur des idées
voilà c'est l'occasion d'échanger c'est
ça avec d'autres entreprises
les cartes de visite alors bon peut-être
pas vraiment échanger les cartes de
visite mais en tout cas de rencontrer
des personnes et au fur et à mesure des
différentes rend compte de faire
connaissance et oui pourquoi pas de
faire connaître l'entreprise mais aussi
s'intéresser aux entreprises qui sont
présentes sur le territoire
le ce type d'événement fait par
l'agglomération c'est bien ça crée de
l'émulation c'est bien ce que fait
l'agglo oui moi j'aime
je suis enfin je participe à différentes
activités qui sont faites est proposée
par
l'agglomération notamment j'ai participé
à la semaine de formation sur différents
différentes demi-journée qui sont
proposées plus tôt dans les ressources
humaines pour ma part qui m'intéresse et
ya pas mal de choses qui sont faites sur
sur saint quentin et qui permettent de
rencontrer des personnes et pourquoi pas
d'établir un réseau wi et bien je vous
remercie madame corps dans c à vous
[Musique]
qu'est ce que le marketing digital et
comment l'utiliser pour son activité
pour répondre à cette question un
atelier organisé le lundi 27 mars de 9 à
11 heures au ski cube à guyancourt avec
plusieurs spécialistes de la question
augmenter sa visibilité est important
les blogueurs et journalistes tournent
naturellement un rôle majeur dans ce
contexte et les solliciter demande un
savoir-faire pour le maîtriser
un atelier prévu mardi 28 mars de 14h à
16h au ski cube agur en cours
c'est la plante se situe t comme merci
de nous avoir suivis
prochain numéro le 6 avril bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]
non